hey dr. Burke here in this short video I
want to teach you something very cool
I'm gonna show you how to get rid of
those wonderful stretch marks I know the
ones that you just love after that
pregnancy or whatever now what our
stretch marks
they are overstretched skin the skin
fibers have gone way beyond their
capacity and the small little micro
fibers get torn as they're over stretch
then they heal with scar tissue that's
why when you're pregnant you should
always rub vitamin E oil into your skin
where you get the stretching I like we
trim well the best now to fix this
you're gonna need three things you're
gonna need vitamin E wheat germ oil okay
so that's the best which is the great
healer especially for the skin and it
does help break down the scar you can
get it in the little pearls because you
can take little pins and pop a little
pearl and pull out the oil the next
thing you need is coconut oil or coconut
butter the same thing and you want to
get it in a jar or some type of
container from the health food store I
have a picture of a coconut there I'm
not saying use coconut you need the
coconut oil and it's a vegetarian
saturated fat now the reason why you're
going to use coconut oil is because of
the type of oil it is on your skin you
have a fat layer that's very similar to
coconut oil it's a saturated fat and by
rubbing coconut oil into your skin it
allows better penetration much better
than other types of oils and you can get
this from the health food store the last
thing you need is a massage tool that
looks like this and those little prong
things can be wooden or plastic it's
like a scrubber
now every here's the procedure every
other night before you go to bed you're
gonna rub one wheat germ oil pearl
you're gonna open up a little pin and
one teaspoon of coconut oil over the
areas of the stretch mark okay so you're
gonna put this oil and this coconut
butter together over the stretch mark
and usually it's in the lower belly so
you'll do one side at a time and you're
going to use the massage tool to rub
these oils into your skin each side for
two minutes okay
two minutes each area and you'll start
with the right and you'll do the left so
that's a total of four minutes now as
you're rubbing and scrubbing over the
scar it's going to turn a little red and
it's going to increase blood flow and
this is increased circulation this is
exactly what you want your skin is an
alive Oregon and what you're doing is
you're slowly breaking down the scar
tissue allowing the blood flow to come
in there and bring hormones into the
area and heal the area now make sure you
do this every other day why because you
need the opposite day of rest to recover
from the the rubbing and the massaging
of the view of the skin so you're gonna
give it a chance to heal you're gonna do
this every other day for in a total of
one month and you're gonna notice that
the scars are gonna fade away very
gradually but don't be fading away some
people depending on the severity might
need to do it for two months okay that's
it that's how to do it go for it